en el vídeo pasado factor izamos este
polinomio para encontrar sus raíces y
los factor izamos primero sacando una
equis como factor común y después lo
factor izamos por agrupación recuerdas y
factorizar por agrupación esencialmente
es usar el inverso de la propiedad
distributiva dos veces y mencioné que
había dos maneras de hacerlo en la cual
podemos resolver esto la primera era
factorizar por agrupación y la segunda
es tomarnos estos dos términos que
tenemos en medio estos dos términos que
tenemos en medio y sumarlos es decir los
dos términos con un exponente medio y a
partir de eso pensar en cómo resolverlo
entonces pensé en hacer un vídeo rápido
usando esa alternativa es decir en lugar
de agrupar vamos a sumar estos dos
términos intermedios y que me va a
quedar y bueno de hecho solamente me voy
a fijar en el polinomio de cuarto grado
que tengo aquí porque bueno ya sabemos
que la equis está multiplicando a ese
polinomio
entonces este polinomio de cuarto grado
si me fijo en el déjame tomarlo con este
color me voy a aplicar en este polinomio
que tengo aquí que me va a quedar si
sumo estos dos términos intermedios
bueno me va a quedar x 4 x 4 y después
tengo 9 x cuadrada menos 2 x cuadrada
bueno eso es lo mismo que 7 x cuadrada
7 x cuadrada y después tengo menos 18
así que lo voy a poner con este color
menos 18 y queremos factorizar este
polinomio y bueno para factorizar este
polinomio lo que voy a hacer es
reconocer un patrón entonces a lo mejor
te acuerdas de él espero que sí pero si
no te acuerdas sería muy bueno que
revisara cómo se factorizar los
polinomios pero bueno qué pasa si tú
tienes la siguiente expresión si tú
tienes el producto de déjame ponerlo
aquí x
por equis más ven esto que te va a dar
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que x
cuadrada después nos tomábamos la suma
de hamás ve a más ve y lo multiplicamos
por equis y después nos quedaba el
producto de estos dos el producto de a&b
pero si esto fuera x cuadrada más am por
equis cuadrada más b bueno nos quedaría
exactamente lo mismo solamente que aquí
tendríamos x a la cuarta potencia aquí
tendríamos x al cuadrado y ya está que
si te das cuenta es justo el patrón que
tengo aquí así que esta vez vamos a
buscar una cierta y una cierta vez tal
que al sumarlas me den 7 positivo déjame
ponerlo así a sumarlas me den 7 positivo
y al multiplicar las mete en 18 negativo
al multiplicar a por de mdm 18 negativo
bueno como su producto es negativo
sabemos que son de signos diferentes es
decir 1
positivo y el otro negativo y como su
suma es positiva
sabemos que el número más grande de los
dos debe de ser positivo entonces los
que a mí me brinqué al nuevo luego es 9
x menos 29 x menos 2 si te das cuenta al
multiplicarlos me dan menos 18 y a
sumarlos me dan 7 positivo entonces
podemos escribir esta expresión que
tengo aquí como x cuadrada más 9 que a
su vez multiplica a x cuadrada menos 2 y
observa está de lujo llegamos a lo mismo
que teníamos anteriormente bueno claro
sin contar esta x que recuerda que no la
estábamos considerando obtuvimos lo
mismo y después dijimos bueno aquí
tenemos una x cuadrada menos 2 lo cual
podríamos factorizar lo por una
diferencia de cuadrados y luego factor
izamos todo para encontrar las raíces
recuerdas pero aquí simplemente te
quería mostrar que puedes resolver esto
por agrupación
usando un método un poco más tradicional
y bueno solamente observa este 9 que
tenemos aquí y este menos 2 que tenemos
aquí curiosamente son este 9 que
teníamos aquí y este menos 2 que
teníamos aquí era justo lo que estaba
separado para nosotros para que gracias
a ello pudiéramos factorizar por
agrupación